we're going to be talking about bond
enthalpy and how you can use it to
calculate the enthalpy of reaction
bond enthalpy is the energy that it
takes
to break one mole of a
bond so one mole of a bond
so different types of bonds will have
different bond enthalpies
so as an example
we can talk about a carbon hydrogen bond
or a carbon hydrogen single bond
so this carbon is probably attached to
some other stuff because carbons usually
have more than one
single bond
but we're going to ignore everything
else attached to the carbon we're just
going to represent it as a big
blob
like popcorn maybe it's a protein it
could be it could be a sugar molecule it
could be a lot of things but we're
ignoring that blob
and
one other thing i forgot to say earlier
is that this is the energy it takes to
break one mole of a bond in the gas
phase
so it's a pretty specific
definition
so in the case of our carbon-hydrogen
bond
the bond enthalpy of this bond
so if we break this bond
let's do a sort of dotted line if we
break this bond
we have to add energy
and what we'll get as our products is
we'll get our popcorn
and what happens is
when we break this bond the two
electrons that originally made up the
bond one of the electrons will go to the
carbon
and the other electron will go to the
hydrogen
and we usually represent
single electrons like that using a
single dot sort of like when you write
lewis structures you can write lone
pairs with two dots
so here's our carbon with one dot
or one electron and our hydrogen with
one electron and these are both still in
the gas phase
so the delta h of this reaction
is the bond enthalpy
which i will abbreviate as be
so some important things to remember
about bond enthalpy are that bond
enthalpy is always positive
so it's always going to take energy
you're always going to have to add
energy
to break a bond
if we take the reverse of the bond
if we take the reverse of the bond
enthalpy
so
another way to think about this is to to
flip this reaction so if we take the
reverse of this reaction that means
we're making a bond
and
since we know that breaking a bond
always takes energy that means making a
bond
always releases energy so it will always
be negative
to
make a bond
and that's another way of saying
it will always release energy
and then the third thing that we're
going to discuss about bond envelope is
that you can use it
you can use bond enthalpy
to estimate delta h of reaction
and delta h of reaction is
or the enthalpy of reaction is something
that chemists are often interested in we
want to know if it's exothermic or
endothermic you might know that there's
lots of other ways of calculating delta
h of reaction such as
using hess's law
or
another way is using delta h of
formation
and then there are other ways too so
this is just another way that we can use
to calculate delta h of reaction using
bond dental piece
so we're going to go through an example
of that next
so the example reaction is taking
propine which is c3h4
gas
and reacting it with hydrogen
so hydrogen gas
to get
propane c3h8
gas
and i don't know about you
i'm pretty bad at looking at a chemical
formula like this and knowing exactly
what the molecule looks like so i'm
going to draw out the lewis structures
so the lewis structure for propine
propine has
three carbons
and one triple
one carbon-carbon triple bond
and then it has four hydrogens
so that's propine
and we also have hydrogen
gas
and our product is propane so propane
has all single bonds
so three so three carbons with single
bonds
and eight hydrogens
bound to the carbons
so that's the reaction we are interested
in and what we want to know here is what
is delta h of reaction
and how can we calculate it using bond
enthalpies we said earlier that bond
enthalpies a bond enthalpy is the energy
it takes to break a bond so what we're
going to do next is look at our reaction
in terms of what bonds are broken and
what bonds are formed and this is a lot
easier to do using the lewis structures
first let's talk about which bonds are
broken
we
if we compare our reactants and our
products
we're breaking this carbon-carbon triple
bond we're breaking this carbon-carbon
triple bond and we're also going to
break this hydrogen hydrogen bond and
one thing we forgot to do earlier which
is super important is we actually need
to make sure our reaction is balanced
and we have
four plus two six hydrogens on our
reactant side and we have eight
hydrogens on our product side that's not
balanced so we actually need two
hydrogen molecules on the reactant side
so let's draw one more in
so yes we said we are breaking a
hydrogen hydrogen bond we're actually
breaking two hydrogen hydrogen bonds
it's important to keep track of how many
of each type of bond we're breaking
because the bond enthalpy is per mole so
if you have twice as many moles it'll
take twice as much energy to break
to break all of those bonds and then we
can look at the bonds that are formed so
we have not since we broke this
carbon-carbon triple bond
that means we
needed to make a new bond
and the new bond we made in our product
molecule is this carbon-carbon carbon
carbon single bond
not only did we form a new single bond
between these two carbons but now these
carbons are attached to a bunch of
hydrogens so we made four
new
carbon hydrogen bonds
so let's write that out so that we can
keep track of them when we do our final
calculation of delta h of reaction
so if we just look at the bonds broken
the bonds we broke
we have a carbon carbon triple bond and
we have a couple hydrogen hydrogen bonds
let's also just write down how many of
each
we have because we'll need that for our
calculation so we have one carbon-carbon
triple bond and we have two
hydrogen hydrogen bonds that are broken
and then
we can also look up their bond
enthalpies which are in kilojoules per
mole
bond enthalpies you can typically look
up in your textbook or online and they
usually come in a table of bond
enthalpies
and so the units can be kilojoules per
mole sometimes you'll also see calories
or kilocalories per mole i already
looked up these bond enthalpy values so
carbon-carbon triple bonds have a bond
enthalpy of 835 kilojoules per mole
and hydrogen hydrogen bonds have a bond
enthalpy of 800. sorry
436 kilojoules per mole and then next if
we look at the bonds that are broken
we have
a carbon carbon single bond
and
and we have
one of those bonds forming
and the bond enthalpy for that which is
also in terms of kilojoules per mole is
346.
and last but not least we have
the carbon hydrogen bonds that we're
forming and we have four of those and
each of those
the bond enthalpy is 413
kilojoules per mole
so now we can take all of this
information and put it together to
calculate delta h of reaction so delta h
of reaction
if we're thinking about it in terms of
bonds made and broken
it's the total energy change during a
reaction
and so it's just the energy
it takes to break all of our bonds and
the reactants
so to break this carbon-carbon triple
bond and the two hydrogen hydrogen bonds
plus the energy
it takes
to make the bonds
to make
new product bonds
we said earlier that you always have to
add energy to break bonds so bond
enthalpy is always positive so we know
this part of our calculation should
always be a positive number what that
means is that it always releases energy
to make new bonds
and when energy is released delta h
becomes more negative so this number
here
when we're talking about adding up the
energy it takes to make new bonds these
should be negative numbers so now let's
plug in the values we have for bond
enthalpy for all of these bonds that are
made and broken in our reaction
let's start with the bonds that are
broken so we have our carbon-carbon
single bond that will require
835 kilojoules per mole
and we have only one of them
and we also have to break two hydrogen
hydrogen bonds so 2 times
436 kilojoules per mole which is the
bond enthalpy of that bond
so that's all of the bonds we break
now we have to add up the energy that's
released when we make the new bonds so
we have this carbon-carbon single bond
so that is
346 kilojoules per mole and that's
negative
because that energy is released
and then the last bond is the
carbon-hydrogen bond
also negative because the energy is
released
and we have four of them and each of
them
will release
413 kilojoules per mole so if we stick
all of this into our calculator to get
our final answer what i got was that the
delta h of reaction for this for this
hydrogenation reaction between propine
and hydrogen gas
is negative
291
kilojoules per mole
we can see that this overall reaction
releases energy
because delta h is negative
so it's exothermic
and that's how you can use bond
enthalpies to calculate delta h of
reaction